I pointed out to Brady
that very soon is going to be our 15th
birthday from our first periodic video
and we wanted to celebrate it and being
Brady he wanted to do something whizzy
to excite you and he suggested that 15th
birthday should be element number 15
which is phosphorus and we have done a
number of videos on phosphorus our
standard video on phosphorus Pete
license burning white phosphorus
phosphine possibly on the planet Venus
and even a suggestion that some bacteria
put arsenic rather than phosphorus in
their DNA which turned out I think not
to be true what we decided to do today
was to find a reaction of phosphorus we
hadn't done before and
I read about reaction of bromine
which is a liquid the element below
chlorine in the periodic table and
phosphorus and you may remember that
phosphorus exists in two forms red
phosphorus
and white phosphorus and white
phosphorus is rather more reactive it
will react spontaneously with oxygen if
it's dry our colleague Jim gamble once
set his tie on fire
with white phosphorus and even when we
were making this video
Neil said to piece of paper on fire with
some white phosphorus
but she quickly put it out so we decided
because the reaction looked as if it
could be quite violent
we decided to begin with red phosphorus
Anil had a nice gas jar
so he poured in some bromine he had some
little vials of bromine and he pulled in
a couple
and you can see the red Vapor of bromine
filling up the gas jar bromine vapor is
very heavy compared to air so you can
see it only Rises slowly up the gastro
in fact we use the hairdryer to
encourage the gas to expand to fill more
of the vessel and Neil put some red
phosphorus in a so-called deflagrating
spoon
this is a Long Rod with a little spoon
at the end and lowered it very gently
into the bromine
[Music]
and it caught fire
I must say wasn't quite as spectacular
as I hoped but it caught fire
then I had the Mad idea perhaps we could
set fire to matches
the sort of matches called non-safety
matches the ones you can strike against
the wall
and which contain phosphorus red
phosphorus so Neil lowered some matches
into the bromine
and nothing happened
I think it's not because the chemistry
was wrong but because Neil's matches
were old
but we can quarrel about that for the
rest of the day so Neil thought let's
try white phosphorus which is much more
reactive and he put a piece of
white phosphorus in the deflagrating
spoon and load it in
but he forgot to dry it white phosphorus
is kept for safety underwater
and so it reacted more slowly than the
red phosphorus which was dry
[Music]
so he got out another piece of white
phosphorus and dried it
and it reacted rather better
[Music]
but still not much better than the red
phosphorus
thank you
but Neil sometimes being more practical
than either Brady or me pointed out that
the red phosphorus is quite a fine
powder
and the white phosphorus was a lump
so the surface area was much smaller
so you have to combine the effects of
surface area
and reactivity
[Music]
at this point Neil really ran out of
bromine
so I was sent to get a small bottle of
bromine and how can I put it my bottle
of bromine was bigger than Niels
whoa and so we had plenty of bromine and
we decided to pour the bromine over the
white phosphorus
we were very careful not very much white
phosphorus in a ceramic dish and
evaporating Basin and it burned but not
terribly spectacularly
of course with all of these reactions
once the phosphorus starts burning it
also Burns in the air especially if you
take it out it often Burns in the air
more dramatically than it does in
bromine and you get clouds of white
smoke which is the phosphorus pentoxide
the oxide of phosphorus but then Neil
decided that really to test things out
he would put the liquid bromine onto red
phosphorus so he put it on a fairly
small quantity of red phosphorus
and it reacted quite well
and then after I'd gone
Brady and Neil decided
to use more red phosphorus
and it went with a bush
[Music]
it was really very exciting the Flames
were drawn across the fume cupboard by
the force of the air being sucked in by
the fans
we never thought we'd get to 15 years we
made all our videos our first videos 120
of them in five weeks and we thought
that was going to be it but you the fans
have kept us going
encouraging us
some of our fans who were little
children are now studying for doctorates
so we're really looking forward to
keeping going to educate the next
generation of chemists and we wish you
all every success with your Chemistry
and there's lots more new chemistry to
come so keep watching
and you can always subscribe to our
patreons
and I've got a periodic table of
patreons here in my office for you to
see
do you think we've got another 15 years
in us 15 more years
I hope so it might be pushing it for me
but you and I hope there will be a new
younger generation of chemists coming on
in Nottingham who can do this as well
the weather's been very cold recently
and I was ready to be shivering but it's
nice and warm but I suppose gold color
also gives you a feeling of warmth so it
may be partly psychological